regardez-moi ça est-ce que vous avez
déjà vu un smartphone comme ça je ne
crois pas il est franchement tout
simplement unique
ce smartphone sans smartphone de
chahoumi c'est le mille huit pros et
franchement il est
[Musique]
cette vidéo est sponsorisé par poulpeo
vous allez voir c'est une solution qui
est hyper intéressante pour faire votre
shopping différemment gagner de l'argent
car vous avez vous explique tout ça à
l'occasion de cette fin d'année il ya
pas mal d'événements sur lequel le
général on fait pas mal d'achat le black
friday et cyber monday un petit peu le
même événement grosso modo il ya aussi à
noël puis après il ya la saint valentin
la fête des mères les anniversaires les
6 décembre n'en finit pas totale mais
bref et l'idée lorsque vous allez faire
ses achats
vous allez dépenser une certaine somme
et grâce à un site que j'ai découvert
qu'ils s'appellent poulpeo vous allez
pouvoir non pas avoir des remises mais
en réalité et gagner de l'argent grâce à
vos achats en gros vous en dépensez mais
vous en récupérer une partie
c'est un système qui s'appelle le cash
back i'll anglaise à l'américaine et en
français on peut plus dire que c'est un
remboursement d'une partie de vos achats
l'idée est très simple vous vous
inscrivez sur le site poulpeo
l'inscription est hyper simple c'est
gratuit c'est pratique et quitte à
dépenser de l'argent autant récupérer un
peu en tout cas ça c'est ma devise
lorsque vous arrivez sur le site poulpeo
c'est extrêmement simple il faut
commencer par vous inscrire vous pouvez
vous inscrire soit par facebook soit par
email soit dire directement que vous
êtes parrainer
je vous mets un code de parrainage
directement dans la description vous
n'avez qu'à cliquer sur je suis
parrainer vous rentrez le code parce que
au lieu de gagner 3 euros qui vous sont
offerts directement à votre inscription
par coulpe et vous aller carrément
profiter de cinq euros de crédit sur
votre compte poulpeo là les étapes sont
vraiment bien marquer c'est intéressant
je recherche ma boutique j'active mon
cash back je fais mes achats j'encaisse
mes économies
c'est très simple comme je me suis
inscris assez classiquement ces trois
euros qui m'ont été offertes mais comme
vous vous allez passer par le lien vous
aurez 5 euros de crédit tu es déjà c'est
cool en plus ce qui est vraiment bien
c'est que là vous avez la possibilité
d'ajouter une extension moi j'ai chrome
vous ajoutez votre extension chrome se
permettra de faire du shopping encore
plus facilement
l'extension et pratique elle est
discrète c'est marqué c'est bien c'est
cool vous avez votre petite icône qui
est juste là qui vous indiquera lorsque
nouvelles sur différents sites combien
vous allez pouvoir toucher directement
en cash back poulpeo alors là vous voyez
vous avez un peu la liste classés par
thématique de ce que vous allez pouvoir
faire alors mode femme mode homme enfant
high tech électroménager s'est tout de
suite ça qui va plus nous intéresser
voyez typiquement vous allez
apple vous avez 3 % cashback et chez
groupon s'est carrément énorme vous avez
12% de remboursement sur vos achats
on va activer le cash back et on va
aller jeter un petit coup d'oeil du côté
de chez groupon cashback active et
d'ailleurs ça vous l'indiquez grâce à
l'extension cashback active et jusqu'à
12% sur groupon un autre exemple la même
manière chez conforama 5% de rembourser
sur vos achats on va aller jeter un
petit coup d'oeil
j'active le cashback cashback active et
conforama
sam envoie directement sur le site du
e-commerçant black friday
waouh et ce qui est complètement dingue
c'est qu'en plus d'avoir des prix
intéressants par rapport au black friday
je vais pouvoir en plus récupérer de
l'argent sur la somme qu'ils auraient
dépensé donc ça c'est franchement hyper
hyper hyper intéressant je vous montre
la même chose sur cdiscount tu pouvoir
récupérer de l'argent sur mes dépenses
par exemple je recherche en ce moment
d'une enceinte de google la google home
mini les déjà eu une jambe et une
deuxième google au mini blanc 46 89
régis est carrément à 77 euros 63 euros
dont j'en ai à tous les prix la rouge
est très sympa c'est pas celle qui
m'intéresse
là j'en ai eu un tarif qui est
intéressant déjà ça touche moins cher
que les autres et en plus de ça j'ai
récupéré l'argent dessus et allez ça ça
m'intéresse
j'ajoute au panier pour le produit qui
m'intéresse sur la recherche dans pool
connectés philips ue
j'en ai déjà pas mal dans studio mieux
compléter voilà là j'ai mon ampoule
white and colors 54 euros 95 au lieu de
59 euros 99 déjà chez lui pour son
économie et en plus je vais récupérer
l'argent sans cette somme
ça me va très bien ajouter au panier
c'est formidable 54 95 44 90 déjà
j'économise de l'argent et maintenant
j'ai plus qu'à passer ma commande pour
un montant de 99 euros 85 sur lequel je
vais récupérer de l'argent
il faut savoir que des 10 euros vous
allez pouvoir faire des virements sur
votre compte bancaire et commencer à
gagner de l'argent grâce à votre
shopping vous allez ensuite recevoir un
email et directement poulpeo qui vous
indiquera bonne nouvelle votre cash back
cdiscount pour moi ou en fonction de la
boutique sur lesquels vous serez a été
enregistré vous voyez donc ici poulpeo
cashback enregistré bout de vos
confirmant votre cash back cd secousse a
été enregistrée vous recevrez un email
de confirmation dès qu'il aura été
validé par cdiscount
là il ya un euro 92 dans ma cagnotte et
lorsque j'arrive
si sûr poulpeo je vois mon gain jamais 3
euros de gains valider des départs
j'aimais un euro 92 qui fait un total de
4 92 ça c'est un début et en fonction de
vos achats
ça va augmenter fonction des plateformes
vous avez des conditions jusqu'à plus de
10 % de cashback donc ça c'est
franchement bien et en fonction du
client ça va également augmenter
donc vous voyez faire du shopping prom
toute autre dimension dans ces
conditions-là autre qui est super
intéressant c'est parrainage partager
votre code de parrainage avec vos
filleuls vous allez gagner 10% avis sur
chacun des gains de vos filleuls
parce que ce qui est cool dans l'idée
est dans le concept même c'est que de
toute façon vous allez faire vos achats
en ligne
vous allez faire des cadeaux à noël vous
allez acheter des choses pour le black
friday
on est tous dans de l'achat et comme il
ya énormément de six partenaires soit
poulpeo est parmi les plus gros sites du
marché je parle de cdiscount parle de
conforama pour le groupe mais il y en a
plein d'autres dans tous les domaines
donc vous allez faire vos achats chez
vos commerçants préférés comme vous le
feriez normalement sauf que là en plus
de faire votre achat vous récupérer une
partie de l'argent pour vous et cet
argent que vous avez récupéré vous
servira peut-être acheter un noël pour
la tat que vous n'aimez pas comme ça ça
vous fera moins mal au coeur d'aller
dépenser de l'argent ou alors vrai
pouvoir récupérer de l'argent pour vous
pour faire d'autres achats enfin c'est
mal assez intelligent c'est sympa je ne
peux que vous inciter à vous inscrire
vous ai mis le lien en bas pour le
'black friday' dans la description vous
pouvez en profiter aussi pour aller voir
pour vos achats de noël
et n'oubliez pas passer bientôt un code
de parrainage pour régner 5 euros au
lieu de 3 euros lors de votre
inscription
on revient tout de suite au 1008 pro
alors d'ici quelques jours on va en
tester un autre c'est son petit frère
c'est le 1008 light je vous invite bien
évidemment à vous abonner dès maintenant
pour tout savoir sur ce mythe light et
pour l'instant on va se concentrer sur
cet objet magnifique qui est le mille
huit pros c'est le vrai vrai vraie belle
réussite qui nous a sorti la chimie
l'origine était de ce produit se trouve
vraiment à l'arrière vous avez si toute
une partie de composants qui est
affichée alors toute une partie de
composants qui est fake c'est pour la
déco c'est pour faire beau mais c'est
hyper hyper hyper bluffant on retrouve
en plus d'une petite finition rouge ici
au niveau des appareils photos c'est
vraiment très très très très joli on
retrouve tout la batterie les composants
et là on a même le slogan innovation for
everyone le slogan de chiots me voilà
c'est vraiment très très très belle
réussite le design de ce smartphone est
complètement à
croyable c'est lui confère une classe
une élégance qui est vraiment
incomparable vous avez si un petit
bouton rouge sur le côté c'est pareil ça
saoule y vraiment ce smartphone il est
vraiment tout simplement très très très
joli vous avez si une grande en cause
parce que vous avez du faceen l'ocs en
infrarouge et vous avez en plus ici le
capteur d'empreintes digitales
directement intégré à l'écran qui marche
très bien qui sera forcément moins
rapide que celui que vous aviez au dos
des smartphones avant mais qui par
contre est toujours son petit effet
brillant termes de design nantes rezé
bord complètement arrondi un petit
manteau en bas l'encoche sur le haut il
est pratique il se tient franchement
bien en main et il est vraiment
extrêmement beau pas très lourd vraiment
un très joli produit
il se recharge en usb type c vous avez
un haut parleur mono ici par contre on
notera l'absence de prise jack il y en a
pas en haut il y en a pas en bas il y en
a nulle part si vous voulez trouver la
solution à se tenir dans la boîte
directement la solution se trouve par là
vous avez un adaptateur prise jack usb
t-il ses premières brancher votre casque
si vous prenez un casque bluetooth ça
fera aussi parfaitement la faire goûter
vous avez une coque transparente à
l'intérieur de toute façon là c'est
évident qu'il vous faut quelque chose de
transparent tout simplement pour
profiter vraiment de l'effet visuel de
ce smartphone à l'intérieur de la boîte
rien devient dingue usb type à us
d'éthique c'est le bloc de charges dont
vous vous aurez un bloc français
rassurez vous mais sinon la boîte est
plutôt sympa on reconnaît vraiment les
codes 2008 qui ont déjà pu tester cette
année là on a une version globale
vraiment très très joli on retrouve un
écran amoled de 6,21 pouces qui ira
parfaitement bien pour tout votre
contenu multimédia 2248 par 1080 pixels
séduit fhd plus à 402 pixels par pouce
ça marche très bien
c'est vraiment hyper appréciable et là
encore c'est pas pousser la luminosité à
fond lorsque je la pousse à fond ça
marche franchement très très bien il ya
un vrai confort lecture c'est hyper cool
l'audio ci est franchement hyper cool
vous avez un seul haut-parleur ici haut
parleur mono mais parfois il ya du son
le son est plutôt cali franchement c'est
bien il ya un mode soleil un mode
lecture autant fait tester très
facilement le mode lecture autant le mot
de soleil en ce moment c'est contre ça
c'est nuageux le temps est couvert
relativement dégueulasse forcément on se
rapproche tout doucement du mode
décembre le mode lecture côté lui
fonctionne plutôt bien pour retrouver
suffit de vous rendre dans vos
paramètres dans vos paramètres
d'affichage modeler
sur up vous venez l'activer ça vous
faire une espèce de lumière un peu plus
jeunes mais vous pouvez venir bien
évidemment la juste et tout ça pour
éviter les lumières bleues pour vous
reposer le regard vous reposer les yeux
ça franchement c'est hyper hyper hyper
important vous pouvez aussi activer le
mode always in pour toujours avoir votre
horloge notification vos informations
sur votre écran
même lorsqu'il est en veille là pas mal
d'autres réglages pour les contrastes
les couleurs ça je vous laisserai jeter
un petit coup d'oeil par vous même en
termes de performances il marche très
très très bien faut dire que vous avez
reste un dragon 845 de l'intelligence
artificielle chose de complètement
optimisé la centrale de faire flinguer
bgg même plus le temps de trouver des
armes je sens que j'ai bientôt y passer
mais bon en attendant je dois dire que
le jeu marche bien ça c'est déjà un bon
point
il faut dire que là dessus vous avez un
score sur en tout ou de 289 1750 ce qui
le positionne entre le black shark de
xiaomi et le 1008 de leur côté à
l'intérieur vous avez 8 gigas de ram
tout ça coupe les os un dragon 845 sa
marche absolument bien en stockage là
dessus j'ai 128 giga de stockage non
extensible les 128 go de stockage déjà
comme ça ça va très bien et peu de vue
gpu gilles adreno 630 tout ça c'est
parfait c'est merveilleux ça marche très
très bien au niveau l'autonomie j'ai une
batterie de 3000 milliampères heures
j'aurais pu attendre avec batterie un
peu plus grosse sur ce genre des canons
des sur le modèle pro de l'atrium de
3200 vidéo par heure ça m'aurait paru
être le grand minimum 3005 3700 arrêté
assez normal en tout cas je trouve voire
4000 milan perd alors on est quand même
sur un modèle qui est des professionnels
le mille huit pros c'est un petit peu
dommage malgré ça l'autonomie est bonne
vous garder une bonne journée ça bien
sûr ça dépend toujours de votre
utilisation si vous êtes hyper gréement
grands consommateurs de jeu forcément
alors trop trop trop d'autonomie si par
contre vous y aller molo molo vous êtes
sûrement sns multimédia quelques jeux
d'eau des appels des choses comme ça
vous garder une bonne journée en plus
qui coule c'est qu'il ya la coupe charge
4 donc ils se rechargent extrêmement
rapidement et tout ça en usb type c'est
bon maintenant on va parler d'un sujet
qui nous intéresse énormément là dessus
c'est la photo vidéo comme vous le voyez
vous avez un double module photo
l'arrière deux fois 12 mégapixels le
premier c'est un capteur 12 mégapixels
avec une ouverture de f 1.8 une
stabilisation optique sur quatre axes
qui vous servira d'appareils photo
principale le 2
c'est un tel objectif toujours 12
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 2.4
qui servira pour le zoom optique x 2 et
pour le mode portrait tech là dessus
vous avez une taille de pixel de 1.4
micromètres qui sera très bon pour
capter de la faible luminosité
vous avez également un autofocus dual
pixels ça c'est un truc qui marche très
très bien chéchia au mythe c'est rapide
c'est réactif vous avez du hdr ou de la
reconnaissance de visage le mode beauté
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle vous
avez de la reconnaissance de scène dans
25 catégories différentes et 206 scènes
différentes qui sont reconnues en plus
de ça vous avez un mode qui est vraiment
cool c'est l éclairage de studio à
l'avant vous avez une caméra de 20
mégapixels vous avez du hdr vous avez
aussi le mode portrait cette fois ci
uniquement logiciel vous avez le mode
beauté foyer pas mal de choses c'est
assez complet en terme de photos et
vidéos en terme de vidéo de films
jusqu'en 4k à 30 images par secondes
vous avez du slow motion à 240 images
par seconde en 1080p ce que je vous
propose d'aller faire quelques photos à
l'extérieur comme ça encore se faire une
idée plus facilement les quelques photos
que j'ai faite fonctionne vraiment bien
l'appareil photo est cool j'adore le
détail regarder le détail au niveau des
gouttes d'eau alors il en train de
pleuvoir ne suis pas resté très
longtemps dehors mais là ça marche
vraiment bien et là on va tout le
savoir-faire de shaolin regarder ça
marche super bien c'est très très très
très sympa il ya un vrai beau boulot
logiciel qui est fait là dessus il ya un
mode qui est aussi super sympa c'est sur
notre portrait parce que vous pouvez
complètement en venir éditer votre mode
portrait comme sur les iphone je peux
régler bon flou d'arrière-plan plus
floue moins floue mon la lumière est pas
forcément terry tout de suite qui fait
que j'ai une tête un petit peu jaunâtre
j'ai pas un très joli teint direz vous
donc je peux venir régler mon food
arrière-plan j'ai ensuite le mode bandes
de lumière que vous avez là hélas aussi
cool parce que regarder ça ne fait des
effets en arrière-plan c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment hyper cool il ya un
jeu qui sait au niveau du foot en
arrière plan ça marche bien j'ai
carrément plus loin je vais ici dans
l'éclairage 3d j'ai une version un peu
noir et blanc c'est assez bluffant ça
marche franchement hyper bien voyez la
petite bande de lumière ce côté là donc
là je change mon éclairage l'orientation
l'éclairage et ça va me changer la bombe
je le fais passer sur l'eau comme ça
franchement
c'est très sympa vous avez aussi
d'autres possibilités là ça vous fait un
effet directement avec votre optique
c'est très sympa les couleurs sont très
jolies là par contre on va tout de suite
le problème de détourage mais sinon le
détourage est plutôt pas mal
bon après là vous avez du gris je pense
que l'arrière plan n'était pas hyper net
bond valable un peu galéré là dessus
mais c'est du pô en italie parce que je
trouve vraiment que l'eau reste en tout
cas est vraiment vraiment bien fait et
là dessus j'ai omis a fait un excellent
travail
si vous avez lu toutes ces races faune
de chiots mis la photo et la vidéo
fonctionne toujours très bien ils sont
sur une solution gagnante le double 12
mégapixels est vraiment hyper efficace
là en plus ils ont rajouté ya des
petites fonctionnalités logicielles
notamment au niveau du mode portrait
c'est juste bluffant c'est vraiment bien
alors mais d'aller encore plus loin
ce smartphone en tout cas en terme de
photos vidéo est tout simplement
excellent marche très bien et je ne peux
que vous le recommander à noter sur ce
smartphone vous avez aussi un double
lecteur de carte sim qui se situe juste
ici du nfc du bluetooth 5.0 il tourne
sous android 8.0 monde doit le retrouver
très rapidement sur android by pour ça
c'est plutôt cool et nouveau capteur
d'empreinte en tout cas situé sous
l'écran je suis pas hyper hyper hyper
fan parce que ils vont quand même
beaucoup moins vite que les anciens le
temps d'attentes est beaucoup plus long
par contre ça marche dès que vous avez
les doigts un peu mouillé ça marche tout
de suite beaucoup moins bien
la voyez c'est assez réactif bon
supporter cette techno demande quand
même en être encore un petit peu
améliorée pour en profiter pleinement
dans l'absolu c'est pas mal en tout cas
c'est assez bluffant on l'a directement
la ces visuels par contre un truc qui a
si bizarre j'ai pas trouvé comment
activer le déverrouillage avec le fun
l'ocs en infrarouge
j'ai regardé j'ai pas trouvé j'ai fait
une mise à jour j'ai vraiment fait la
dernière mise à jour je suis sûr me why
9.6 point 5.0 j'ai pas trouvé bon
écoutez si vous savez pour le marquer
directement en bas en commentaire est-ce
qu'il va y avoir une mise à jour très
prochainement peut-être c'est possible
en tout cas en terme de logiciel c'est
pas mal il ya un second espace qui est
disponible que vous pouvez activer
lorsque vous allez le prêter à quelqu'un
à votre enfant à le partager à plusieurs
et votre compagnon coup pourquoi pas on
peut l'imaginer compagne ou compagnon
ça c'est plutôt cool des applications
clown également pouvait clown et
facebook vous pouvez cloner les réseaux
sociaux instagram snam chat ça ça peut
aussi avoir un sens au fond on a
plusieurs comptes
bon ça fonctionne bien il faut aimer
cette version de me wade parte
ça me pose absolument aucun problème je
trouve ça assez sympa peut dire que
penser de ce huit pros de shiomi déjà en
termes de look
il est franchement incomparable par
rapport à beaucoup d'autres smartphones
qui sont très jolis par exemple je vous
en france j'aime beaucoup c'est le
médecin prouve qu'il ya eu un vrai beau
boulot de fait je suis quand même
beaucoup plus amoureux du modèle de chez
lui d'une huit pros que du mail 20 pro
par contre avec d'impro en termes de
photos c'est tout autre chose mais je
trouve que le design le fait d'avoir ces
composants transparent comme ça c'est
vraiment hyper bleu france est vraiment
très très très joli ça franchement sympa
qui est très positif le fait d'avoir
c'est pareil sept petits boutons pour
l'allumer en rouge servir souligné le
design du produit
après il ya l'encoche on l'est on n'aime
pas il ya un petit menton bah c'est pas
non plus d'écho dans l'encoche sur l'eau
pour c'est l'année prochaine ça va
disparaître on voit que c'est un modèle
de fin 2018 très clairement parce que
l'année prochaine
vous n'aurez plus dans cochant aux
autres toujours un petit manteau en bas
pour des questions techniques mais on
l'a déjà vu sur la vidéo j'ai sorti sur
le mx3 ça ça va disparaître en 2019 vous
allez voir il y aura plus dans coche
mais par contre si on arrive à nous
sortir un produit avec un dos aussi
élégant sur un mix 300 encoches là par
contre je dis banco le smartphone juste
magnifique alors après en terme de
performance
il est vraiment bien vous n'êtes pas une
claque à un 1800 qui a pouvoir avoir de
plus c'est le capteur d'empreintes
digitales sous l'écran ça pour moi c'est
c'est la grosse innovation de cette fin
d'année on la surnommait grimperont la
soie loin de plus 6 t on retrouve
également sur le mille huit pros en
termes de photos sont toujours très
maîtrisée de la partie chimie sur cette
gamme de produits double capteur 12
mégapixels ça marche très bien ça
fonctionne parfaitement bien en termes
de photos vous serez absolument pas déçu
en termes de performances il est aussi
excellent pour aller jouer à des jeux
typés ubg tout ce que vous voulez il
encaisse parfaitement bien avec son
snapdragon 845 et ses 8 gigas de ram et
là maintenant je vais répondre au
téléphone parce qu'ils ont atteint de
l'année wells en train de tourner une
vidéo du coup tu veilles dedans ça te
dérange pas à la hâte en jeu mais les
haut parleurs comme ça tu peux dire
bonjour à tout le monde voilà alors tu
peux dire bonjour voila
bonjour bon j'en étais où c'est son
super je vous disais la photo très bien
je vous disais la puissance très bien je
disais de design très bien ce baiser le
smartphone très bien est ce que je vous
ai pas dit le prix 1
voilà le prix 599 euros c'est un budget
c'est une vérité c'est une certitude
mais je peux vous assurer que par
rapport à la qualité du produit il est
extrêmement bien placé parce que si vous
regardez on comparatif un petit peu avec
le one plus ce système doit le système
un peu près au même prix 555 170 5 190
ch et plus exactement mais c'est
sensiblement le même prix capteur
d'empreintes digitales
sous l'écran double module photo les
deux fonctionne parfaitement bien vous
avez un plus grande encore une plus
petite encoche là vous pouvez
déverrouiller dans la nuit avec
infrarouge sur votre système
ce n'est pas possible finalement c'est
possible quand ça marche moi j'ai pas
trouvé une je pense à marcher si c'est
en tout cas vendu comme ça de la part de
xiaomi le design là dessus est vraiment
magnifique
j'aime bien celle du web du système et
ça je suis vraiment très très très très
fan on voit qu'on est sur deux produits
qui sont quand même relativement
similaires après la question c'est dire
qu'elle marque votre coeur balance plus
chaud me + one plus voilà ça c'est plus
aux sirènes une question un peu de coups
de coeur par rapport à la marque en tout
cas il ya un vrai vrai vrai vrai mon
boulot qui est fait là dessus de la
partie aux miches sais pas ce que vous
en pensez vous comment vous trouvez
qu'on peut pas rester insensible à ça
c'est pas possible c'est humainement pas
possible vous marquer ce que vous en
pensez un banc commentaire comment vous
le trouvez ce mail huit pros est ce que
vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
en tout cas si vous voulez vous et c'est
tenter vous pouvez pas ce que je vous ai
mis un lien en bas dans la description
faites vous plaisir d'ici là soyez sages
et je vous dis d'ici quelques jours on
va tester le 1008 flight qui est juste
là c'est son petit frère un pavé fiche
technique on fait pas la même chose
on a un instinct dragonne 660 un écran
6,26 pousse un double module caméra 12 +
5 vous voyez ça change un petit peu mais
enfin je pense qu'il ya aussi des choses
qui sont très très très sympa puis
surtout il est quand même moins cher
voilà merci à vous il est allé consulter
la pianiste pour découvrir tous les
smartphones du moment savoir lequel est
bien lequel pas bien le style ça tout ça
voilà bref soyez sage je vous embrasse
et à très bientôt
ciao